[music]
>> Who can say surah name first, then
chapter number,
then the meaning
faster than 2 minutes?
2 minutes 3 seconds.
Who can say faster than 2 minutes 3
seconds? 1
Raise your hand high. 1 2 3
Whichever order you learn, you ask me to
change again. No, no. You have to say
that order.
If If you are expert, if I tell you to
speak from top to bottom, you should
learn 114 direct. Surah An-Nas, chapter
number 114, mankind.
Surah Al-Falaq, chapter number 113,
backward, in, out.
You have done in school.
You can't give that excuse. Someone else
tells me
That means you haven't
strived hard.
When you become an expert, then not
first standard, second grade, anything
you ask.
Who can do faster than
2 minutes 3 seconds? 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 Seven people.
Okay.
Brother Firdous.
Bismillah.
Surah Al-Fatiha, chapter number one, the
opening. Surah Al-Baqarah, chapter
number two, the cow. Surah Al-Imran,
chapter number three, the family of
Imran. Surah An-Nisa, chapter number
four,
the woman. Surah Al-Ma'idah, chapter
number five,
the table spread. Surah Al-An'am,
chapter number six, the
the cattle. Surah Al-A'raf, chapter
number seven, the height. Surah
Al-Anfal, chapter number eight,
the spoils of war. Surah At-Tawbah,
chapter number nine, the repentance.
Surah Yunus, chapter number 10, the
prophet Jonah.
Number 11,
prophethood. Surah Yusuf, chapter number
12, prophet Joseph. Surah Ar-Ra'd,
chapter 13, the thunder. Surah Ibrahim,
chapter 14, prophet Ibrahim. Surah
Al-Hijr, chapter number 15, the rocky
track. Surah An-Nahl, chapter number 16,
the bees. Surah Al-Isra, chapter number
17, the the night journey. Chapter
number Surah Al-Kahf, chapter 18, the
cave. Surah Maryam, chapter number 19,
Mary. Surah Taha, chapter number 20, the
two Arabic word Taha. Surah Al-Anbiya,
chapter 21, the prophet. Surah Al-Hajj,
chapter 22, the pilgrimage. Surah
Al-Mu'minun, chapter 23, the believers.
Surah An-Nur, chapter 24, the light.
Surah Al-Furqan, chapter 25, the
criterion.
Masha Allah. Takbir.
Takbir.
How much?
1 minute 18 seconds. Very good job. But
just a suggestion.
You did a very good job. Excellent.
Most of the people were not paying
attention because they could not see
you. I could see you.
Very good job.
But see, when you're doing something
which is difficult,
from your face,
it was looking that, you know, your
eyeballs were up.
You did a very good job. I'm not making
fun of you.
But no one was looking at you. I was
looking and smiling.
You did a very good job, but anyone
looking at you will realize that you're
in turmoil. You did a very Very good.
Better do it than not do it. But next
time, you ask your colleague
or your roommate,
"How's my face?"
See, I get up. Brother asked a very good
question. In my mind, there is
Mahabharat. Mahabharat means, you know,
there's a battle going on. Well, how to
answer? But my face is Brother asked a
very good question. So, you do not let
what is going on in your mind be
reflected on your face.
Others also had tension.
But alhamdulillah, saying with tension
in 1 minute 18 seconds is better than
without tension 2 minutes. Very good
job. [snorts]
But I'm trying to make you go to a
higher level.
The art is
you do not let the opponent know
what is happening.
Sheikh Didat,
may Allah grant him Jannah, thinks,
"Son,
people are cursing YOU AND YOU'RE
SMILING?
AND YOU'RE SMILING?"
SHEIKH DIDAT WAS
knockout punch.
Direct. We'll deal with it when we come
to the debating session. So, you do not
reflect what's happening.
Especially if it's negative. If it's
good, then no problem.
If you are happy, then happy no. But
what is negative going on in your mind,
it should look like you're telling cake
walk.
But check again. It may not be.
It may not be. You don't reflect what's
happening.
All the people are struggling.
So, inshallah, you did a very good job.
1 minute 18 seconds, very good. Who can
better 1 minute 18 seconds? Raise your
hand.
Who can better 1 minute 18 seconds?
Raise your hand.
First 25 surah.
Only one?
Arsh?
Fariq?
Sorry?
Which order?
But when you quote in the lecture, how
you quote?
Imagine if I say it's of the Quran,
chapter number one, Surah Al-Fatiha,
then verse number 20 or so.
As I used to say,
chapter number one, verse number 23,
Surah Al-Fatiha. Will it make sense?
When you quote in the lecture, how do
you say?
No flow, nothing. If you tell me to say
in whichever order,
I will say it.
If you know your work well.
If you don't know your work well,
then
Who can say in the order? Same order.
Better than 1 minute 18 seconds.
How many people?
Who'd like to try?
Not confident.
2 3
5 6
Who's confident that he can do better
than 1 minute 18 seconds?
Raise your hand.
Who's confident
that inshallah I can do it.
Who's confident that inshallah I can do
it.
1 2 3 4
5 6 No, you're finished.
Second chance. It's all that I said once
cannot come back. We don't have that
much time. 1 2 3 4 5
6 7
Okay, brother Arshi.
A'udhu billahi minash shaytanir rajim.
Bismillahir rahmanir rahim. After you
start, you stop.
Surah Al-Fatiha, chapter number one, the
opening. Surah Al-Baqarah, chapter
number two, the cows. Surah Al-Imran,
chapter number three, the family of
Imran. Surah An-Nisa, chapter number
four,
the women. Chapter Surah Al-Ma'idah,
chapter number five, the table spread.
Surah Al-An'am, chapter number six, the
cattle. Surah
Surah Al-A'raf, chapter number seven,
the height. Surah Al-Anfal, chapter
number eight, the spoils of war. Surah
Tawbah. Surah Tawbah, chapter number
nine, the repentance. Surah
Yunus, chapter number 10, prophet Jonah.
Surah
Hud, chapter number 11, prophet Hud.
Surah Yusuf, chapter number 12,
prophet Joseph. Surah Ar-Ra'd, chapter
number 13, the thunder. Surah Al-
Surah Ibrahim, chapter number 14, the
prophet Ibrahim. Surah 15, Al-Hijr.
Chapter Surah Al-Hijr, chapter number
15, the rocky track. Surah An-Nahl,
chapter number 16, the bees. Surah Al-
Isra, chapter number 17, the night
journey or the children of Israel, Bani
Israel. Chapter number Surah 18, chapter
Surah Al-Kahf, chapter number 18, the
cave. Surah Maryam, chapter number 19,
the Mary. Surah Taha, the abbreviated
letters. Surah Taha, chapter number 20,
the abbreviated letters. Surah
Al-Anbiya, chapter number 21, the
prophet. Surah Al-Hajj, chapter number
22, the pilgrimage. Surah Al-Mu'minun,
chapter number 23, the believers. Surah
Surah An-Nur,
chapter number 24, the light. And Surah
Surah Al-Furqan, chapter number 25, the
criterion. Masha Allah. Takbir.
Takbir.
What was the timing?
40. 4 0.
4 0.
>> 4 0
4 0
Two names twice.
That's your choice.
Do you think you have missed out the two
names you had then it's lesser than 118?
>> [laughter]
>> Is he right?
I can try again. No, no, try again.
Now you divide, you said two extra.
Instead of 25, you said 27. Even if you
divide it, it will not come lesser than
118.
Do you agree? 140 would come down to how
much? Fast.
100 seconds.
4 seconds per sura. You delete it.
Minimum it would be 1 minute 32 seconds.
Or 31 seconds. Not less than that.
Therefore, when you give an excuse, if
it was 3 4 seconds less,
don't give excuse which will not work.
It may work with others, but not with
me.
Correct?
It's good. Alhamdulillah. 1 minute 40
seconds is good.
It's not bad. But seeing that you know
about it, it's good. It's not very good.
For him, it's excellent.
Who can confidently make it less than 1
minute 18 seconds?
See, when you had a bus going, then you
had a train, then you had a fast train.
Now people from Japan use bullet train
and are experienced traveling bullet
train.
Who going to faster than
1 minute 18 seconds?
Raise your hand.
Who can inshallah do it faster than 1
minute 18 seconds?
1 2 3 4
>> [music]
[music]